Speaker 1: Last week, I did a segment for
our TikTok account, which, by the way, Tik
Tok, over 500,000 followers on TikTok.
It's crazy what's going on.
We're reaching.
Young people were wild.
Things are happening on TikTok.
I did a segment where I laid out why I don't
think the impact of Trump's arrest will be
limited only to the presidential race.
And the point I made was that there's going
to be a significant trickle down effect.
Now, I'm wondering whether I did this for
Tik Tok or for our Straight Arrow news partnership.
But in any case, I do remember talking about
this maybe even on the bonus show now, I don't
remember.
My argument is as follows It would be wrong
to assume that Trump's trials and indictments
will only affect the presidential race.
I believe that it will affect down ballot
Republicans, and it has the potential, depending
on how this all goes over the next 6 to 18
months, to generate an insane amount of chaos
for Republicans trying to get themselves reelected
in November of 2024.
If you are a pro-Trump acolyte and you're
trying to get reelected and Trump really has
legal issues and is damaged in the primary,
maybe loses it or wins, but then loses to
Joe Biden, it could turn off a lot of people
from voting for their local elected official
House or Senate for reelection.
On the other hand, if you take the anti-Trump
side as a Republican seeking reelection in
2024 and Trump prevails, that could end up
being very damaging to you.
So there's a lot of risk here.
Too many in the Republican Party.
And as we talked about late last week, Republicans
are worried that Trump is going to drag them
down.
We now are really starting to look at trial
calendars and Republican debates, schedules
and primary schedules.
And it is hard to come away with any conclusion
other than the one that Newsweek has come
across or come to believe, which is that,
as they say, Donald Trump is likely to be
swamped with multiple overlapping criminal
trials.
This is the one scenario other than a health
problem that could derail Donald Trump's campaign.
Newsweek writes Donald Trump is at risk of
being faced with multiple criminal trials
at the same time, all while campaigning to
become president in 2024.
Tuesday, Trump pleaded not guilty to 37 federal
offenses connected to the Jackie Smith Documents
case and is expected to appear next in Florida
court in June.
It is currently unknown when a trial could
be set for the classified documents case,
with the decision to be made by Judge Eileen
Cannon.
Of course, as we talked about, appointed to
the bench by Trump facing calls to recuse
herself, the article continues.
The New York trial will will take place.
This is the other trial.
The New York trial will take place while the
Republican primary is well underway.
And after the so-called Super Tuesday, where
several states vote on the same day elsewhere,
there have been indications that the criminal
investigation in Georgia is drawing to a close
and Trump could face former indictments.
That's going to be sometime between July and
September, probably here.
They're talking about July and August, etc..
A Fani Willis is office says federal indictments
will not have any impact on the Fulton County
election investigation, saying what she is
doing is going to happen regardless of what
is happening federally.
And then it's also important to remember that
Donald Trump is potentially going to be federal
indictment indicted an additional time related
to January 6th.
So when we.
Think about what could derail Trump.
A health problem.
But that could happen to anybody.
Anybody could be derailed by a health problem.
The political scenario that could derail Trump
is that he is so flooded with criminal trials
that he quite literally just can't keep campaigning.
It pulls him off the campaign trail.
Trump has pledged to stay in regardless.
That is his pledge.
But Trump says things all the time that end
up not being true.
This is really a cautionary tale.
It's best to commit only one crime per year
so that you can keep your schedule clear.
I'm sort of kidding.
Of course, Trump is innocent until proven
guilty.
I still doubt at the end of the day that the
path away from Trump in this primary is that
he drops out or that the path out of Trump
in this election is that he drops out.
I see it as far more likely that Trump stays
in.
Wins the primary but loses to Joe Biden in
2024.
I believe that is the most likely scenario.
The second most likely scenario is Trump stays
in the primary but loses the primary.
Less likely, but still possible.
And I believe the least likely scenario is
that Donald Trump bails on the primary and
even less likely I think it's Trump dies and
is no longer a candidate.
I would put that as fourth.
That's my order for this at the end of the
day.
It really is up to Republicans to decide what
it is that they want.
And right now, although the polling is moving
a little bit and I know we're going to look
at polling later this week.
The polling is moving a little bit, but Trump
is still very much in control.
Chris Christie's argument is when you talk
to the Trump supporters today.
About half of them or more say I do support
Trump as of today, but I'm open to supporting
somebody else.
Chris Christie's argument is, if you take
the people who are definitely not supporting
Trump in the primary and then you add to that
the number of people supporting Trump but
willing to vote for someone else, that's enough
to win.
And Chris Christie is correct mathematically.
The question is, what would it take for that
group that says I support Trump, but I'm willing
to look elsewhere?
What would it take to get them to actually
look elsewhere?
And even two more indictments, I don't believe
is going to change their mind.